all right oh Sam Samantha if I recall
um
your question is what do you do for a
living by the way
okay
what did you do
what's that
you say marketing
okay
Pat you hiring
seems like a nice person
do you know a digital marketing by any
chance
Sam where'd you go to school
Boston University no
oh tu's good school
you know he's lying because his voice
went real high
all right all right your question's a
little wonky
have you ever brought groceries to a
comedy show to save yourself a trip
you brought your groceries with you
tonight
okay
how is everybody at Thriftway tonight
what what grocery store
I get that that's that's actually pretty
classy
you come by at Trader Joe's you stop the
[ __ ]
I don't know who the [ __ ] runs that
snack department but God damn
[Applause]
they are unbel they put [ __ ] together
you won't even think of
that's crazy
he's gonna be talking about food for the
next nine minutes I forgot everybody I
knew it
how how
big of an order was it thank you
and can fully have half of it
just to shut them up
how much did you spend at Trader Joe's
20 30 bucks okay what do you have any
produce
do you have like a head of lettuce on
you right now is what I'm trying to get
at
Sam what did you buy
you brought cans of tuna to a comedy
show and you had the balls that asked me
if that's trashy
that's what homeless people would do
and you can get that [ __ ] at any other
grocery store
you're rolling around with cat food on
you it's not like you got one of their
vegan dips or like anything like they're
like one of their frozen pizzas or
empanadas you check them out their fake
husband
you got cans he sounded like you were
underwater for a second
okay
[Applause]
also the worst part is she had to check
it at the front door
I do like a nice tuna sandwich
this one's just funny it's from Rachel D
have you ever been a customer at a store
within a store for example a hair salon
at ShopRite
[Laughter]
if you're getting a cut at ShopRite
[Laughter]
you're buying tuna for sure
laughs
holy [ __ ]
a bank baby
Starbucks even still
okay all right my head hurts
this one came in from a gentleman who
goes by Ed from Delco
[Applause]
where are you at Eddie
ah there he is yeah
what's up brother who are you here with
him okay
for Jordan graduate college one thing I
learned
you roll around you introduce people
these are my two favorite bartenders
what what's the name of the
establishment you 10 Barack guys
hey yo let me ask you a question how did
Cheesesteak egg rolls at Pinocchio's
I bet they're [ __ ] fantastic
two dollar you call it's all night long
dude foreign
bartenders
wow don't make them choose man
all right Ed what do you do for a living
pal
yeah I'm a wastewater operator
man you really church that up
what the [ __ ] does a wastewater operator
do
okay yeah
there's no operating at all
foreign
is it garbage if your parents delay
taking you to the to the ER with a
blatantly broken bone because they have
dinner reservations
what was Pinocchio serving that night
it's playing chowder or something
you can only get the lemon chicken on
Thursdays hold off you little [ __ ]
did they take you to dinner with you Ed
that's why they fired me from a teaching
job
[Laughter]
also he's so trashy in his in his
question in parentheses he goes my
finger was Facing East laughs
a real medical term I believe
it's like a crow on the top of a barn
yeah
he's like look it's Facing East now it's
facing west
oh do you remember where they went to
that night
I mean hey come on
be [ __ ] reasonable
did they take you with them
oh yeah I was caught in a porterhouse
with my finger
Affairs of multiple people sharing that
porterhouse I meant
and the boys give him a round of
applause and if you're in a neighborhood
stop by Pinocchio's
Pinocchio all right hello Med send you
uh we got time for one more then we
gotta get out of here Phil you've been
[ __ ] awesome give yourself awesome
[Applause]
this one uh is from Trevor a is it
garbage to take the pepperoni off of
frozen pizza and save them in a Ziploc
bag the service is as a charcuterie
board forget
Billy you've been [ __ ] awesome baby
we love you can't wait to meet you
outside thank you so much good night
thank you